welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and season six of
Rick and Morty has finally come to a
close with their latest Christmas
special we've got some major speculating
about season seven to do but today I'm
taking you frame by frame through season
six episode 10 of Rick and Morty and
breaking down all the details you might
have missed let's start with the episode
title frictional Rick poom's Rick
mismortation is the play on National
Lampoon's Christmas Vacation a late 80s
holiday comedy starring Trevy Chase it's
no secret that Dan Harmon and Chevy
Chase had a falling out on the set of
community so I guess this is an example
of this series putting aside any grudges
to honor a Christmas classic we open on
the Rick and Morty logo decked out in
Christmas lights before being taken to
the snowy driveway of the Smith Sanchez
home where space Beth's ship is parked
next to Rex when we first see the fam
gathered at the foot of the Christmas
tree keep Jerry's sweater that reindeer
looks like the festive version of the
deer that Beth had to save in season 2's
A Wrinkle in Time Rick shoots a portal
on the floor and drops straight down
through it foreshadowing the other
vertical accidents to come this episode
he re-emerges as Rick Sanchez bearing
gifts from across the Multiverse
including including an extra dimensional
extended edition of Miracle on 34th
Street when Jerry puts it on for the fam
later we can see that it's the original
black and white 1947 version of this
movie not the 1994 John Hughes reboot
starring Mara Wilson love that Jerry
still has a VHS player especially when
Rick's international cable box crystal
is sitting in plain view for Beth Rick
travels to a dimension where she wasn't
murdered as a child and he wasn't an
absentee father to obtain childhood
photos of the two of them together when
space Beth opens her copy it's an image
of Beth writing on her dad's shoulders
sharing a mint ice cream cone with him
as we learned in both the rickshank
Redemption and Rick Marie Jack Rick's
original Beth was killed by Rick Prime
and Morty's real grandpa is the true
rickist Rick our Rick's Beth also
happened to be killed as the family Was
preparing to go out for ice cream which
makes this Photograph all the more
Bittersweet summer gets what looks like
500 sent to her Vemma account today's
video is sponsored by Babel one of the
top language learning apps in the world
I'm going home for the holidays and one
of my best friends from childhood's
grandmother is the world's greatest cook
she speaks zero English I always feel
bad not being able to give her a
compliment Beyond a Clean Plate and
thumbs up but with Babel I can change
that Babel specializes in preparing you
for real life encounters and situations
Studies have shown that 15 hours of
using Babel is the equivalent of a
semester of college of Spanish and 15
hours in Babel flies back I can watch
videos listen to podcasts play games or
do lessons whatever kind of learning
mood I'm in Babel's got something that
fits the bill I like how they gamify
learning I have daily goals and
achievements that I can unlock as I
learn the language I'm pretty early in
my Babel Journey but I have started to
learn some useful phrases like okay Des
fruto
companies
get up to 60 off your subscription when
you click the link in the description or
scan the QR to start learning with Babel
today Morty it's the real prize a real
life blue lightsaber just like Luke
Skywalkers from A New Hope before he
hands it to him Rick says Morty you ask
for this a long long time ago when I
finally went Far Far Away enough to get
it paying homage to the opening Scroll
of Star Wars the two raced to the garage
to play Jedi where it turns out the Rick
has set up a whole fruit cart for Morty
to slice and dice at a reference to the
game Fruit Ninja where it constructs
Morty to strike him down insisting that
he'll just become a pile of clothes like
that old guy when Obi-Wan fights Vader
for the last time at the end of a new
hope he tells Darth that if he strikes
him down he shall become more powerful
than he could possibly imagine moments
later Vader gets him with the lightsaber
and Ben Kenobi disappears leaving only
his Jedi robes behind when Rick hits the
lightsaber and vanishes Rory asks him if
he's t-shirt Rick now calling back to
his Grandpa's previous forms like tiny
Rick Pickler Rick and you get the idea
unfortunately less than 10 minutes after
getting the coolest Christmas gift of
all time Morty drops the lightsaber
perfectly vertically and it begins
sinking through the ground reminding me
of this bit from Robot Chicken where
Anakin drops his lightsaber through the
floor maiming those below ironically Ben
Kenobi tells Luke in a new hope that
lightsabers aren't as random or clumsy
as blasters but that's clearly not
always the case to catch it before it
causes more damage Rick and Morty raced
through the underground levels of Rick's
lab level 1 and his weapons and
generation Chambers level 2 is full of
alien plants one of which we saw
previously in season 5's
thanksploitation spectacular and level 3
features several creatures in a red
liquid type cryosleeper seen in season
4's the old man in the seat they even
find a cool ass sushi restaurant on
level 15 but the good [ __ ] is what's
happening on level 10 where Morty finds
the real Rick tinkering away remember
last episode when Morty asked Rick if he
was a robot and Rick replied that there
were already enough clones and robots in
the family yeah he lied because he's a
goddamn dirty robot who will die if he
tells the truth remember that throwaway
joke about the lightsaber's postage
pricing from the opening it turns out
that it was a hint that robot Rick can't
solve the are you a robot captions
without going against his programming
Rick decided to build a robot that would
be 22 nicer to his grandson after Morty
called him boring in a wrecking King
mortar's Mort we've been with robot
Ricks since he rescued Morty from the
Sun robot Rick even tried to subtly tell
Morty that there was a robot hiding
amongst the family God damn it Rick I
trusted you and I was brainstorming on
how summer could be introduced as a
robot and you made me look like a ding
dang fool now I know how Morty feels I
thought that therapy was helping
especially because he made so much
progress this season towards bonding
with his family and letting go of
unimportant battles but now that lasted
about 8.2 episodes before Rick got butt
hurt and decided to give his life some
purpose this is just another Crow God
thing where Rick can't handle it when
Morty is disillusioned by him instead of
looking within himself and doing the
work like Dr Wong suggested he just
throws himself into his latest hyper
fixations that he doesn't have to
actually change or feel anything and
listen dude I get it your neighbor Gene
is annoying and most David Arquette
rules are boring but don't you dare
disrespect the scream franchise or
officer Dewey in this household if you
want to take it out on Netflix dramas
that aren't accidentally good that's
fine I wasted seven hours of my life on
the Watcher too so I get it this isn't a
complete reversion of Rick's season 9
character growth however Rick's actions
as piss Master were the real deal and
through that Adventure Rick realize that
being obsessed with a nemesis will
destroy you and your family this is why
Rick replaced himself with a Kinder
wreck so the family could have the
grandfather they deserve while he finds
Rick Prime to get closure on his
family's death so that he can move on in
the background we see what Rick is
working on to help him catch Prime see
those robot Parts in that chamber that's
one of the killbots that attacked Rick
and Morty in the first episode of season
six so lyrics towards the end of the
episode we see it up close as Rick
blasts through its pieces to find a
thumb drive that he believes will lead
him to Rick Prime we also see Rick
studying Prime's hologram but comparing
it to other Rick butts throughout the
Multiverse crimes butt identification
number is 34C wrp 195 and I got really
excited because I was like 34C that's my
bra size I didn't know we were using the
titty system to measure butts now I'm
going to talk more about Rick's Manhunt
later on in the video so hang tight
outside the presidential Blackhawk
touches down on the Smith's front line
and the president explains to Morty that
the lightsaber he dropped is a mile deep
and still falling soon it will reach the
Earth's core causing it Chain Reaction
that'll destroy the planet it's a bit
like firing a proton torpedo down a
hatch in the Death Star if you think
about it when the president mentions the
lightsaber's hilt his security detail
yells out that they're powered by kyber
crystals that guy is definitely subbed
to new rock stars and knows his Star
Wars lore after delivering an
impassioned gen next speech about why
Star Wars sucks the president sets up a
team of scientists and military
personnel to help intercept the
lightsaber the portal used by these
government agents was first seen in
season 3's the rectory Morty date and
according to their countdown clock they
have roughly an hour 20 to catch it
before it hits the core although Rick
warns the scientist not to touch his
[ __ ] or it'll kill them this dude boops
one of his devices and disintegrates he
tells the president that if he wanted
the government in his house he'd just
buy an Alexa because we all know that
Jeff Bezos sees you when you're sleeping
and knows when you're awake the
president reports by telling Rick that
he looks like Phil Spector wiped his ass
with Randy Quaid referencing to
inarguably unattractive Hollywood
criminals the latter of which also
starred in Christmas Vacation alongside
Chevy Chase as and Eddie it turns out
that Rick has a lightsaber of his own a
Sith verticeaber whose prime directive
is to always remain vertical
unfortunately the lightsaber Rebels
turns off its brain and tunnels to Italy
where it slices through a crowd of folks
just trying to enjoy the Venice canals
when the president sees the Carnage he
says that is definitely not Amore
referencing Dean Martin's that's amore
amore translating to mean love in
Italian president Curtis also pulls a
classic U.S government move and blames
the Carnage on the Saudi Arabian Royals
although they managed to get the
subterrain drill like a submarine but
for Earth working Rick storms off
instead of hopping into the cockpit
because he's still super angry at Morty
for calling him boring this machine's
design is kind of like a mix between the
drill from 1976's at the Earth's core
mixed with a lightsaber and their race
to the earth center itself is a
reference to disaster movies like 2000's
deep core or 2003's core which I totally
thought was the same movie until today
this week's Inside the episode talks
about the scenario being like a Michael
Bay movie referencing the inspiration
this plot takes from 1998 Armageddon
despite the president's Valiant attempt
Morty's the one who spectacularly
catches the Rogue lightsaber and he
proudly proclaims May the force be with
me to the crowd of waiting scientists
and military personnel his victory
short-lived however as the president
steals this elegant weapon from a more
civilized age when Morty accuses him of
not even liking Star Wars because of his
whiny ass speech earlier the president
replies that Star Wars belongs to him
because he was around Morty's age when
the original trilogy premiered in the
late 70s and early 80s but after the
third move it got all muppety something
in him began to rot and he openly blames
George Lucas and Disney for his rage he
even mocks Lucas for his gout which
Jesus Christ is not cool man he's
clearly gatekeeping the fandom and
despite having access to his own source
of lightsabers he simply doesn't want to
let Morty enjoy it if you're confused
about why Gen X and the president are
still mad at Star Wars I highly
recommend that you check out Barney
Stinson's explanation of the Ewok line
Theory it states that Star Wars fans are
divided into two groups though was born
before May 25 1973 and those born after
anyone to the left of the Ewok line born
between 1960 and 1973 was at least 10
years old when Return of the Jedi hit
theaters on May 25th 1983. because of
this they were too old to be swayed by
the adorableness of the Ewoks and left
to [ __ ] about how unrealistically the
OG Trilogy Ended as the president was
roughly 14 when these movies came out he
was likely 20 when he finally saw a
return those born to the right of the
Ewok line however likely saw it as young
children and are therefore okay with the
ewok's presence in Star Wars with an
empty bowl on his head the president
pretends to be Luke Skywalker deepening
his connection with the force by wearing
a helmet with a blast Shield like a
dumbass he also drops the lightsaber
vertically through to the core of the
earth and I think we all understand now
why becoming a Jedi takes years and
years of training but back at the Smith
Sanchez home Morty reveals to his family
that the Rick they've been spending
Christmas with was a robot the whole
time even after playing am I a robot
with him Beth space Beth Jerry and
summer simply believed that Grandpa was
finally leaning into the holiday spirit
to teach them valuable lessons about
vulnerability and family fun as soon as
they realize that this is robot Rick The
Smiths attack him Jerry cuts open his
arm with a turkey Carver space Beth
shoots him with her Blaster Beth slices
his arm off with a broken wine bottle
and summer stabs his eye out with a fork
afterwards they decorate their Christmas
tree with the robot's body parts only to
realize that the president and Morty
might need his help again after
rebooting robot Rick with a battery
packing Christmas string lights and
rebuilding his body with some
sea-thropio looking Parts he and Morty
head to the White House which the
president has blasted into space in
order to avoid Earth's impending
explosion inside they find probably the
coolest hidden secret kept by any U.S
president an entire room dedicated to
Star Wars built by President Carter not
only is there a replica of the Moss
Eisley Cantina complete with working
kegs courtesy of George W there's also a
giant Recreation of the window from the
Death Star it's got several droids and
other Machinery too that guy right there
it looks like it could either be an atxt
or an atst and the president deploys an
army of lightsaber-armed pitroids in the
same way the battle droids and attack of
the Clone are unleashed the
lightsaber-eyed robot also reminds me a
little of ks20 from Rogue one and we've
got a TIE fighter and a TIE fighter
Advance stored in the rafters my two
favorite parts of this room however are
the Mini model of the death star's
trenches and vice president Dwayne from
season 5's Thanksgiving episode frozen
in carbonite like Han Solo Morty nearly
gains the upper hand but unfortunately
for him robot Rick jumps in front of the
mini lightsabers headed straight for the
president their vertical fall cuts a
hole in the bottom of the White House
and he Morty and robot Rick are nearly
sucked into the vacuum of space luckily
Rick portals them safely back to the
garage well not totally safely robot
wreck is still dying interestingly we
see red and blue wires hanging out of
his right eye exactly like when evil
Morty removed his eye patch at the end
of season 1's close rate counters of the
Rick kind before he passes on to the
world wide web in the sky robot Rick
tells Morty that because Rick literally
built him to make his grandson happy
there was still a true part of the real
Rick that wanted to show more support
towards his grandson he also encourages
his human counterpart to do a little
more for Morty on his own without the
aid of technology or distractions Rick
decides to take this robot variance
advice and invites Morty to join him on
level 10 to look over his progress in
finding Rick Prime along with his
specific butt number and hologram we see
the map of hundreds of red dots for a
second time and Rick explains that those
aren't just the places his Nemesis could
be they're the places he is this word
choice makes me think that each dot is a
killbot Zone where Prime has set up
traps all across the Multiverse or the
rickus Rick has somehow managed to
divide his Consciousness amongst
different hosts in various Dimensions
kinda like the intergalactic version of
horcruxes they could also Simply Be
decoys we know that even decoy Ricks
love to make decoys from season 5's
mortalicity so I wouldn't put it past
prime to place watered-down versions of
himself in different locations to force
Rick to kill hundreds of him him before
finding the real him in the same way
that he gave Rick a 50 50 shot at
catching him in solarics he could
escalate forcing Rick to search for him
like a needle in a haystack Rick offers
to let Morty help him hunt down Rick
Prime in place of his previous 100 years
Rick and Morty's speech he repeats the
phrase you and me Morty in regards to
finding and killing Prime as grandfather
and Grandson you can even see the
alcohol dribbling out of his mouth when
he loses his [ __ ] despite his mouth
being clean for the majority of the
season of course he specifies That
season 7 won't entirely focus on this
storyline it'll just be a couple of
episodes sprinkled in kind of like they
did with evil Morty before him although
it does kind of break my heart that he's
diving back into his obsession with
finding his original wife and daughter's
killer he made so much progress in
solarics even telling Diane's voice that
he had to move on from her haunting him
to remain in the moment with his new
family but obviously that episode was
chekhov's variant and of course we need
closure on Rick Prime as much as our
Rick does during the credits we pull out
to find Mr Poopy butthole watching the
episode on Hulu while he's getting yoked
at the gym if you zoom in the video
player tauntingly begs for its viewers
to re-watch its content self-aware of
how frivolous television is and how
media corporations design their web
players to Loop us into giving them more
watch time Mr Poopy butthole has a habit
of showing up in post-credits scenes and
this season's post-credits mirror season
fives where Mr pbh was watching evil
Morty's grand plan unfold in that scene
we learned that he never got his life
back together after sending his students
to the hospital in season Four's one
crew Over the Cuckoo's Morty and that
his wife Amy left him there's a fan
theory that Mr Poopy buttholes become a
self-insert for showrunner Dan Harmon
and that his divorce was inspired by
harman's 2015 divorce and there does
seem to be some Merit for that theory
here as Mr Poopy butthole's personal
trainer looks like Dave Klein Harmon's
personal trainer but pain isn't just
mental in this CrossFit inspired dungeon
of pain poopy butthole tries to bench 90
pounds and breaks a leg in the process
crying out for Amy if this self-insert
theory is true don't expect Amy and
poopy to reconnect though instead expect
him to find himself and settle down with
the writer of a criminally underrated
gem on interdimensional quippy follow me
on Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]